your dreams have a purpose but those  dreams are not necessarily to be  fulfilled they are a vehicle that gets  you moving there is something so much  better in store for you than that dream  there's something bigger had i achieved  my dream of being a new york times  best-selling author if i had had a  successful traditional book launch i  never would be where i am right now yeah  there's no way no way satisfied your ego  temporarily correct for the two weeks or  whatever that it was on the list it's  what gave me that high five attitude  this mantra i kept saying this to myself  on repeat there is no way mo if you've  worked this hard that you will not be  rewarded you have to believe that this  moment is preparing you for something  amazing that hasn't happened yet keep  going